moviegoers remember some landmark films
how green was my Valley the rains came
the late George Appling David and
Bathsheba the ghost and mrs. Muir pinky
ten North Frederick the agony and the
ecstasy those were just a few of the
screenplays written by one of the
cinemas most prolific authors the
recipient of the Writers Guild highest
honor the Laurel award he is here to
bestow this year's Oscars for
screenwriting mr. Philip Dunn
thank you water after that introduction
I feel a little like the late George
applet whether a writer uses a quill pen
a lead pencil a battered typewriter with
missing letters or a mind-boggling new
word processor he'd better start with an
idea movies are ideas and the screenplay
is the art form that expresses them that
fact is too often overlooked by
audiences and reviewers but never by
those who make the movies and so we
salute the nominations to the best
screenplay written directly for the
screen this year they are Barry Levinson
for Dinah Melissa Mathison for ET the
extra-terrestrial
John Briley for Gandhi Douglass days do
it for an officer and a gentleman
Larry Gelbart Mauritius go and Don
McGuire for tuxie
and now for the winner the winner is
John Briley for gondol
I wrote a long movie I'm gonna make a
long speech I know I like everybody who
stands up here I've got a lot of debts I
just want to acknowledge three one two
Dickie Sir Richard for having the faith
and courage to trust me with his dream
put up with me once it became mine too
and fulfilling both our dreams with such
brilliance and honesty and too been for
a performance that went beyond dreams
for me it's still emotional to watch Ben
although I've seen it like 50 or 60
times I think it's so moving and so
profound that it does an honor to our
whole industry and justice even to the
man that inspired the whole film and
then I would like to thank McGann D
himself when I came to this material I
despaired for it as drama and I didn't
think it had much relevance in a world
as cruel and as harsh as ours but as I
came to know the man I'd found that he
knew everything we all know about our
cruelty our selfishness our greed our
fears but he also had a faith in the
kind of stubborn resolution that we all
have to be a little humane to be a
little understanding to be a little even
brotherly and he lived his life in a way
that showed that if we called upon that
in ourselves and in our enemies that
there was hope for each of us and maybe
for this planet he gave me that I tried
and writing the screenplay to give it
back in a way that he would have proved
I thank him I thank you
after some 50 years of grappled with the
challenge of adapting other authors
published works I have enormous
admiration and more than a touch of envy
for the inventive writers nominated for
the best screenplay based on material
from another medium
they are both young Pattison for this
boat costa-gavras and donald stewart for
missing Alan J Pakula for Sophie's
Choice David Mamet for the verdict
like Edwards for victor/victoria and the
winner in this envelope is costa-gavras
and by accepting the screenplay
for missing mr. Donald
on behalf of my co-writer and friend
costa-gavras I'd like to thank the
members the Academy that notice this
award we owe it to a lot of very brave
people who gave their art and their
hearts to missing but above all we owe
it to Charles de Norman thank you